what threat does Russia pose to the UK
it's a question the cross-party
Intelligence and Security Committee of
MPs has been looking at examining topics
including espionage subversion and
possible attempts by Russia to interfere
in votes like the brexit referendum with
the face of the leave campaign now in
Downing Street Boris Johnson is the man
who will give final sign-off to the
report the committee says that should
have happened on Thursday number-10 says
it usually takes six weeks this is
completely untrue they're talking about
the six week process by which you clear
it through the agencies and the Cabinet
Office we're not talking about this
we're talking about the final clearance
by the Prime Minister and I really get
worried when an authoritative voice like
number 10 starts putting out these
completely bogus arguments with MPs due
to leave this place next week to start
campaigning Tuesday is the final chance
for the report to be published before
the election it should be released and I
suspect that the reason it hasn't been
published is they're going to try and
delay it past the dissolution of
Parliament on Tuesday in there they can
hide it away until some point in the
future if a report has been called for
and written and should be in the public
domain then what have they got to hide
Sky News understands an mi6 agent from
the Russia desk gave evidence as part of
the inquiry these sensitivities mean the
intelligence agencies and the Cabinet
Office are required to clear the report
ahead of publication that has already
happened which is why the committee says
the Prime Minister's sign-off should be
a formality one non-party political
source with a knowledge of the process
said the deadlines and timetables were a
gray area but added they couldn't see
any reason why number 10 shouldn't
publish the West is increasingly aware
of the threat posed by Russia and
arguments over the extent of its
interference in democracies like the UK
will continue for now though it appears
this latest contribution to the debate
will stay under wraps
brob Powell Sky News in Westminster